How do you pick up knowledge of how to
act well,
that's not quite as explicit.
It's not as easy to figure out,
you know,
obviously you know the children up a lot
of information by modeling behavior,
which is basically a copy adults and
that basically means they watched adults
act with their body through space and
they duplicate those patterns of action.
Can you generalize from them?
So that's one way behavioral wisdom is
transmitting something that is explicit
as well,
at least in terms of the receipt of
rewards and punishments because parents
will modulate their children's behavior
by engaging and motivationally
significant interactions with them.
At least that's what you should do if
you're a parent.
That's your primary responsibility in a
sense.
So that's what we mean when we say that
you're paying attention to someone.
That basically means that you're
modulating your behavior with your
behavior,
with your emotions.
So like a child will monitor or parallel
marcher is child would react positively
when something that the parent wants to
happen happens and negatively.
When something happens with the parent
doesn't want to happen.
So the child's behaviors,
well that's just classical reinforcement
theory.
Basically you exchanged rewards and
punishments and threats and promises and
behavior.
We do that all the time in their
interpersonal interactions.
That's part of the reason why people
with personality disorders can sort of
have an uncanny effect on you,
which is to say if you're a personality
disorder,
do you have a really potent expectation
about how someone else will behave
usually like a son of a bitch
fundamentally,
and if someone with a personality
disorder encountered someone who doesn't
talk like that and they're a challenge
to their belief system,
people with personality disorders are
extremely good at turning everyone.
They meet into the same person that they
already met and they do that.
I think by exchanging very,
very subtle and covert reinforcements,
which is to say,
you're engaged with me and I have a
personality disorder.
Every time you act properly,
I'll ignore you or say something
contemptuous or look away or do
something quite subtle and every time
you act like a miserable bastard,
which is nice to expect.
I'll at least pay some attention and
possibly even reinforced you covertly.
And you'll find if you get close to me,
that you,
it's almost like you'd been distorted by
a gravitational field as you paid your
starts getting pulled in strange
directions.
We do that to each other all the time
and one of the things you might consider
as well,
these are very large.
We're all engaged in these patterns of
mutually modifying interactions and
something emerges from that stable.
I guess I would say that the things I'm
going to teach you about mythology or
the things that I do as stable,
emerging properties from risk from
centuries of reciprocal interaction.
So if we're engaged in some pursuit,
you're going to notify me and I'm going
to modify you and neither of us really
know precisely what that means because
we're not conscious of all the reasons
that we do everything.
And that's just been.
I mean it's bad.
Not if there's only two of us,
but if it was like 50 of us will,
then you can imagine the calculating all
the permutations of the interactions
become virtually impossible.
Point is we will settle into some sort
of stable configuration or disappear.
Those are the options and that human
societies do settle,
settle into stable configuration,
so we don't really understand how that
happens,
but we we have developed the ability to
describe those configurations without
understanding of it.
I think that makes up a big part of
mythology.
The stories we tell ourselves about how
we behave when we don't know how or even
why you things to consider in the
future.